salam haleikoum armateurs barracato
alfred je tiens à remercier l'assistance
aujourd'hui avec nous aussi le projet
initiative pour leur aimable invitation
à venir parler de mon métier de musicien
de chef d'orchestre mais aussi de
manager je remercie beaucoup les
étudiants de bug soit parce que j'ai une
pensée réelle parce que j'ai été
étudiant à bab ezzouar pendant une année
parce que je voulais faire de
l'informatique
donc j'étais dans les locaux de
l'université pendant une année mais
après la musique a fait appel à moi et
je me suis donc consacrés uniquement
pour des études en musicologie
donc je suis amoureux d'elle je suis
chef d'orchestre directeur artistique de
l'opéra d'alger
ici au lait de faillite chef d'orchestre
aussi à l'international puisque je
dirige l'orchestré philharmonique
internationale à paris et je suis
artiste de l'unesco pour la paix tout
mon parcours a été jalonné par beaucoup
de difficultés mais beaucoup de
découvertes et j'en parle à partir du
moment où j'étais étudiant et ce monde
d'étudiants est quelque chose de
formidable parce que toutes les
possibilités sont ouvertes
tout est possible quand on a vraiment
envie de réussir et de s'inscrire donc
dont la performance s'inscrire dans la
recherche de la connaissance s'inscrire
dans une optique de travail et aussi
d'excellence ce qui forme de toute façon
la personne déjà et fait grandir la
personne pour faire grandir le projet et
on m'a toujours appris les maîtres que
j'ai eus m'ont dit toujours il faut
absolument progresser personnellement
pour faire progresser vos propres
projets et par rapport à ça c'est ouvert
une nouvelle vision pour moi c'est une
vision que j'aimerais vraiment partagé
avec des études que je suis très proche
des étudiants moi-même d'objets été
formateur donc à l'institut national de
musique alger donc j'ai formé des chefs
d'orchestre des chefs de choeur des
musiciens et aussi comme chef
d'orchestre
mon métier c'est aussi d'être là au
service des musiciens puisque en fin de
compte c'est eux les premiers qui font
l'acte musicale il faut savoir que le
lors qu'istres c'est une société est
presque on peut faire le parallèle avec
d'autres sociétés
ce soit une société donc civile ou bien
aussi une entreprise puisque le musicien
il y est il a un rôle exactement comme
celui donc d'un un salarié d'une
entreprise est bien entendu ce chercheur
qui serait dirigée par un manager et on
travaille tous dont l'objectif de
réussir un concert c'est l'objectif
ultime
mais pour ça nous avons besoin de
beaucoup de choses on a besoin de
l'administration donc un chef
d'orchestre connaître aussi les besoins
de l administratif de son orchestre
il doit connaître les besoins en termes
de communication et doit connaître les
besoins en terme politique générale de
la culture
décidée par ministère de la culture si
lorquet cela dépend des ministères de la
culture en tout cas ce qui est le cas
pour nous en algérie
il doit aussi connaître aussi l'aspect
complètement nu purement musical donc
voyez vous c'est déjà une somme de
beaucoup d'éléments que doit maîtriser
le chef d'orchestre pour qu'il puisse
vraiment mener à bien son travail
ça c'est la première chose lors qu'elle
serait constitué par trois grandes
familles d'instruments pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas un orchestre symphonique
et des instruments à cordes et les
instruments accord pour chaque
instrument il ya plusieurs personnes
dans plusieurs personnes qui travaillent
et qui font presque le même travail dont
une grande section nous avons les
instruments à leysin sur la famille d'un
instrument à vent
hélas les instruments à vent ils ont
beaucoup plus de responsabilités parce
qu'il n'a pas beaucoup par rapport aux
cordes
donc nous avons deux flûtes au lieu de
seize premiers violent par exemple et la
responsabilité elle est différente et
bien entendu il ya les percussions donc
il ya très peu de percussion parce que
ça fait énormément de bruit ça donne
beaucoup de musique et donc le chef
d'orchestre de par son mouvement de
baguettes non seulement bien entendu il
donne le tempo
c'est à dire la vitesse de déroulement
de la musique et donne des indications
en termes de son si le son est grand ou
petit mais aussi il va donner une
direction en termes de cinq réunions de
l'ensemble de ces instrumentistes parce
que chaque instrument mais un certain
temps pour arriver au niveau du public
donc le chef d'orchestre par cette
baguette va essayer synchroniser tout
cela donc si on fait le parallèle le
parallèle est très simple donc c'est
exactement comme un chef d'entreprise
qui lui même doit connaître le travail
du salarié doit connaître aussi le
travail de sa section administrative de
sacs section financière de sa section
communication de marketing etc etc et le
chef d'entreprise doit absolument
trouver les sous pour faire en sorte que
son projet puisse aboutir
complètement et c'est en ce sens que
c'est intéressant donc moi je au fur et
à mesure de mon travail j'ai commencé à
remarquer des choses qui ont un
parallèle avec des amis qui travaillent
dans des chefs d'entreprises d'autres
qui sont dans des grands conseils de
cabinet de conseil et je me suis
vraiment intéressé à 7 7 7 qui dirige ce
parallèle est donc j'ai commencé à
développer donc tout un travail de
formation de management à travers le
leadership du chef d'orchestre il faut
savoir que le leadership du chef
d'orchestre il est beaucoup donc utilisé
dans d'autres les formations pour les
managers parce que manager par
excellence et bien autres de il est son
savoir mais aussi il ya aussi un savoir
de communiquer un savoir pour travailler
avec les équipes 1 a aussi un savoir
pour essayer d'aller jusqu'au bout des
choses
donc il ya bien entendu comme je disais
tout à l'heure un travail personnel et
comme chef d'orchestre
nous avons tout un pan dans notre un
autre travail au mation comme chef
d'orchestre il s'agit bien entendu donc
la régularité du travail trouver des
solutions être réactif par rapport aux
problèmes trouvaient toujours des
solutions par rapport au problème et ça
passe par une chose très importante
c'est la connaissance
nous on musique on dit on ne peut pas
aimer sans connaître et la connaissance
c'est la connaissance première la
commune la connaissance pure il faut
qu'elle soit déjà une connaissance
humaine une connaissance de coeur et une
connaissance intellectuelle une
connaissance de l'esprit on dit que nous
avons besoin de l'intelligence du coeur
qui est mélangé l'intelligence de
l'esprit pour avoir une symphonie une
harmonie et à partir de laquelle on peut
vraiment être au service de la musique
pour transmettre cette beauté de la
musique qui nous vient de beaucoup de
compositeurs qu'ils soient algériens
arabes africains
occidentaux pour arriver donc à
l'oreille de l'auditeur qui lui va venir
pour écouter parce qu'il a besoin de 2,7
de cette musique pour qu'ils puissent
grandir au qui puisse s'évader pour
qu'il puisse avoir une plus value en
termes de temps donc comme je dis
toujours moi je suis juste un chasseur
de mouches avec la baguette
parce qu'une fois après un concert
qu'elle a 12 heures atelier holy-dis mal
et je vous pose juste une question ça
sert à quoi un chef d'orchestre il était
en concert où je me suis content là ça
sert à rien du tout il faut pas le dire
at les noirs dit moi dites moi au delà
d'un chef d'orchestre chasse les mouches
qui commence après ce que vous avez vu
une mouche voler ce soir les noms et la
balade vous ai fait mon travail de chef
d'orchestre
ça c'est une petite anecdote pour dire
c'est vrai que le métier de chercheur
caisse est pas très connus ou pas
suffisamment
mais en tout cas l'idée c'est de dire
qu' il y a toujours toujours une base
pour nous c'est la connaissance et je
disais tout à l'heure d'ailleurs à
quelques étudiants c'est que la
connaissance aujourd'hui est différente
est différente de celle d'avant mais
aussi le moyen d'accéder à cette
connaissance est beaucoup plus facile
aujourd'hui qu'il y a une vingtaine ou
trentaine d'années d'année contre compte
nous on était étudiant et c'est ça qui
est formidable pour les étudiants
aujourd'hui ils ont cette possibilité de
grandir
là où ils sont par rapport à des
informations qui peuvent avoir
mais comment transformer ces
informations en connaissance et pour
servir quoi et dans quel objectif
en fin de compte c'est il faut qu'ils
aient à la base donc une partition à la
base un objectif très très très précis
par rapport à ça et c'est donc dans ce
sens que moi je dis toujours étudiant il
faut vraiment vous imprégner de tout ce
qu'il y a mais aussi cette connaissance
doit être aussi à 360° dans le sens par
exemple nous en musique ou en art quand
vous avez un spectateur du côté droit de
la scène un autre du côté gauche
on va poser par exemple un objet je
demande aux éclairagistes de maîtres de
la lumière rouge ici et de la lumière
verte ici celui qui est là il verra que
la lumière verte et celui qui est là bas
ils voient la lumière rouge
ils sont dans la même salle en même
temps y voit deux choses différentes
donc on fin de compte c'est comment dire
est ce côté relief qui est très
important dans la connaissance on fait
quand il faut se placer à la place de
l'autre pour comprendre ce qui se passe
et pour pouvoir réagir par rapport à ça
donc d'où l'importance vraiment de
connaître les choses à travers plusieurs
comment dirais-je plusieurs visions
échanger son paradigme par moments parce
qu'on se dit oui moi je sais faire ça
comme ça et donc je le ferai que comme
ça alors dès qu'on commence à penser
autrement à 360 degrés les choses
deviennent complètement équilibré c'est
pour ça que moi j'aime beaucoup les
métiers
et j'assiste régulièrement des
conférences je me documente sur beaucoup
de choses que je ne connais pas qui sont
d'ordre technique
je suis très curieux intellectuellement
pour comprendre les mécanismes et pour
essayer de les reporter par rapport à
mon métier de chef d'orchestre pour
essayer de mieux résoudre des problèmes
que que nous avons c'est ce que je dis
toujours musicien et l'idée c'est d'être
aussi comme étudiant faire partie d'une
équipe alors que j'étais étudiant
après boire j'étais à l'école normale
supérieure de combat donc des
professeurs où j'ai fait une licence en
musicologie avant de partir à l'étranger
on nous avons créé une chorale
c'était la première et à la première
chorale donc de l'université ce qui
était formidable c'est pas juste le fait
de réunir quelques étudiants et de
chanter mais c'était le fait de fédérer
tous ces personnes autour d'un projet où
il y avait des discussions où il y avait
des réflexions il y avait des échanges
qui était très important pour mener à
bien tous notre projet et ça c'est le
partage nous comme musicien on partage
les émotions on partage des sonorités on
partage le moment et le moment tant est
complètement différent selon la
sacralité dans laquelle on met les
choses ou pas et donc j'ai appris
beaucoup de choses avec cette courte et
je me suis dit c'est vraiment un moment
privilégié de pouvoir partager des
choses avec vraiment l'esprit et le
coeur je l' ai appris aussi à l'étranger
après avoir fait mes études au
conservatoire de marseille conservatoire
de paris conservatoire de copenhague au
danemark
et puis après à saint pétersbourg à
l'opéra de saint peter j'ai dû remarquer
des choses extraordinaires c'est des
gens qui ne sont pas juste des musiciens
mais c'est des gens qui respire la
musique y parle musique
ils pensent musique ils sont musique et
ça c'est quelque chose qu'on connaît
peut-être moins quand je fais un projet
je deviens moi même ce projet je le mène
à bien complètement avec tous les moyens
je dispose mais on n'a pas tout tous les
moyens même en termes individuel
donc je m'abreuve je m'instruis auprès
des autres donc c'est toujours un
travail de partage tout ça voilà c'est
ce que je voulais partager avec vous ce
matin merci pour cette invite est bon je
dis bravo emile bravo pour les étudiants
de bab ezzouar que je salue
particulièrement puisque j'en ai j'ai un
des étudiants et merci pour l'honorable
à distance merci pour ses sponsors qui
sont en train d'aider donc tout ce
travail qui est formidablement intérêts
il faut savoir aujourd'hui on a beau le
dire non le redis l'avenir appartient
aux jeunes mais aux jeunes qui font
aussi un travail pour leur avenir
merci beaucoup c'est la maladresse
notoire